are you good at betting i'm pretty okay
do you trust that inner voice
my inner voice comes in and say let's do
it that's what we're gonna do
i'm madeline burke here with
indianapolis legend
reggie wayne we're out here at indiana
grand racing and casino every time
i get off the plane in indianapolis it
feels like i'm at home
we've got an action-packed day out here
in your city
so i'm gonna let you take the lead on
this one you ready let's do it let's go
how many horses do you think run in this
next race i got butter noodles in this
one
i'm going with perfect seeker i like
peanut butter i like that number seven
[Music]
here we go here we go let's go
perfect seeker let's go butter no
no strong start butter i need to know
what your inner voice
says this quarter is going to do got to
call it in the air ready
all right we gotta go two out of three
high score drops back perfect seeker
there we go
hits oh butter noodles what are you
doing come on
what are you doing he peeked too early
are you serious
all right so you win the coin toss but
hey as reggie knows winning the coin
toss
doesn't always mean you're winning the
game
[Applause]
look let's go look at this it's not even
close it's not even close
buttered i'll tell you you gotta go by
the name
oh my god
he won by like eight horse lengths too
we gotta turn this up a notch a little
bit
something a little different oh you're
gonna like it i like where your head's
at
considering that i was voted worst
driver in my high school like i feel
like this is this is a big moment for me
personally okay
hey guys welcome to indianapolis motor
speedway world's largest sporting venue
we're gonna have some fun today
[Music]
what's up you guys how are you doing
good to see you so um
quick question how long do you think it
takes to to change a tire
i was born on the 17th so i say 17
seconds i'm thinking 15 seconds
it's a good bet well you're a little bit
far off because it really should be
about
four to six seconds and we're willing to
show you what that might look like right
over here
you want to come check it out i need to
call
aaa all right so this is uh
this is our pit crew so they're going to
give you an example here of uh
a real tire chain so i'll give you guys
how it's done fellas three
two one go
boom it's like four seconds to me all
right picture us coming in 60 miles an
hour
ready to slide into the pits all brakes
locked ready to go go
there you go okay pretty absurd
a little dragging i'm a little i'm a
little uh
okay 12.3 12.3 no
no solid no it's on you come on maddie
all right get ready three two one
go
how you change a tire gentlemen the
stopwatch does say that
yep that would be a 12 second time and
that's faster than this
that is faster than this legend right
here no way
no it's cool very impressive it's cool
you know you got you got your
championship titles and other sports
oh mine this is mine it's the moment
i've always dreamed of
in my entire life
i feel like a champion right now you
look like one thank you
guys
this has been an awesome day today we
got to say a special thanks to bleacher
report
to indiana grand racing and casino to
indianapolis motor speedway and
especially
to reggie wayne the local living legend
i'm madeline burke thank you so much for
hanging with us